let's go back to summer of 2012 Sheryl
Sandberg has just announced she'll be
publishing her first book lean in the
book is called
as a call to action to women everywhere
to lean into their careers and rise with
the ranks of Corporate America before
the book is even published there's
numerous responses in the media
including an article titled why women
still can't have it all written by
anne-marie slaughter former senior
official at the State Department
slaughter writes about the near
impossibility of women to balance a
demanding career and motherhood in the
work environment as it currently stands
a few months later I received my
acceptance letter to Stanford Graduate
School of Business and the margins of
the letter Derrick had written in
cardinal red ink Jennifer the lessons
your mother imparted on you will ensure
that you contribute grow and learn at
Stanford because see when Stanford asked
me what matters most to you and why it
was the easiest question undoubtedly my
mom who equipped with the master's
degree dedicated her life to raising my
two siblings of me there were 22 schools
in Spain Mexico Korea Hong Kong and the
all to exotic state of New Jersey so
there I was so excited of having just
been accepted to the GSB and yet there
is a sense of confusion in the media was
this ongoing debate not simply on how
but whether women could balance a career
and motherhood and yet the very reason I
was accepted into this institution was
because of a woman who had never held a
title other than Allah or mom I asked
myself where was my mom's voice in this
debate on how I'm supposed to lead a
life balancing career and motherhood
which brings us to today here at the GSB
where I learned there's a number of
alumni female alums who question whether
the GSB should be accepting as many
women given the number of alumni who
have
dropped out of the workforce to be clear
this is not a GSB problem when asked to
comment for an article in The New York
Times the former Director of Admissions
at Harvard questioned what return do we
expect from educating women The Guardian
chided a little more bluntly that
educated women have a duty to stay in
the workforce all these arguments over
value the return generated by
professional achievements while
undervaluing the role of full-time
mothers and also dismissing the value
that we women currently in schools bring
to a diverse learning environment to say
the least it struck a chord and I'm
thrilled to be here speaking to you all
today in defense of my mom's decision
and the decision of countless women who
chose to become stay-at-home moms now I
realize I'm about to step into a
minefield as this topic of educated
stay-at-home moms touches on
socio-economic issues gender dynamics
parenting values just to name a few and
I encourage all of you to explore all of
these nuances before today I want to
focus on us our GSP community and to be
clear I'm not trying to advocate for a
certain decision but merely to lend this
stage to the countless voices that go
unheard because their arena of work
isn't the most private of private
sectors their homes in preparing for
today I had the privilege of speaking
with women from the class of 79 to 2005
learning about their experiences as
full-time moms their stories were as
unique as they were stereotypical LuAnn
GSB class of 79 during our time at home
organized professional development for
the young presidents organization served
as auditor of her children's PTA and
worked with the Children's Health
Institute and San Francisco Symphony now
how is her passion for all this
volunteer work any different from our
ambitions of becoming leaders and
mentors and organized
but then there was Tracy class of 98 who
vowed never to become a stay-at-home mom
since she was 10 years old and her
father unexpectedly left her family
leaving her mother as a sudden
breadwinner but after several
miscarriages her dream of becoming a
mother became contingent upon her
leaving her career and nurturing her
first child from the moment of
conception I asked Stephanie class of
2001 what impact her GSB education has
had on her and she confided the finance
I don't use every day but the soft
skills I learned I use all the time and
is this any different from what we hear
from the countless CEO alums who come
back to campus they told me stories of
early frustration where they long for
the intellectual challenges of the
careers they left behind spending days
with the child who couldn't walk nor
talk let alone walk the talk but these
days would be balanced by in comparably
rewarding days where they were witness
to their child's first steps and first
words seeing the impact of their endless
encouragement speaking with these women
has been an absolute blast they have
given me the confidence that right now
without a ring or child I have no
decision to make but their voices are
loud and clear in my head that should
anyone choose to work full-time as a
mother it is an entirely individual
respectable and fulfilling decision so
then who are we as members of the GSB
community and broader society to be
alarmed or disappointed by these women
who are changing lives of the leaders of
our future changing organizations
whether as mom and chief we're head of a
non-profit and is changing this world
each and every day if I were to ask a
roomful of people say you all
who is the person you most admire we're
sitting here in Silicon Valley maybe
someone will say Steve Jobs roomful of
MBAs perhaps we'll get a Warren Buffett
maybe we'll even get the leader of this
nation and I'll wager although each by a
different name
a handful myself included will say it is
their moms that they most admire so why
don't we give our women our alumni our
peers who choose to dedicate themselves
to the noble profession of motherhood
the respect and admiration they so
rightfully deserve thank you